I heard that you screen-tested for
Captain America that's a goal in my head
I got the part yeah what was that was
that process like because that's the
real question you when you're trying to
think like am I am I one of those
superhero guys or not you know what I
want to do that could I do that so when
you had that test what was it like it
was a big deal for me because I mean
first of all I love those Marvel movies
I'm loved superheroes
I love imagination so when they asked me
to test they actually allowed me to put
on the suit I was on a set it was all
very interesting I feel like as I'm
talking about this someone from Marvel's
new book and just like yeah but I
remember the the only bummer of it was I
was putting on the suit just watching I
was like this is so amazing and I got
about right to my waist I was still
shirtless feeling pretty good about
myself wasn't 13 hours yet but night I
felt pretty good and all of a sudden
Chris Hemsworth walked by his door and
he's like by night and I went I'm good
this is stupid
I love you Thor yeah it's like my name
is Chris it's like whatever
you